time magazine has just announced its
athlete of the year for 2021
simone biles the gymnast who took a spot
on the u.s olympic team and then
infamously refused to compete in a bunch
of events biles eventually blamed her
pulling out on having the twisties but
initially she chalked pulling out up to
quote not having as much fun she said
i feel like i'm also not having as much
fun and this olympic games i wanted it
to be for myself and it felt like i was
still doing for other people and that
hurts my heart that doing what i love
has been taken away from me
because that's that's what the olympics
are about it's just you and not your
country and not the sport just but just
so it's all about you
so the woman who refused to perform an
athletic event won athlete of the year
specifically for refusing to compete six
years after a man named bruce jenner won
woman of the year from glamour magazine
and rather than criticize
these two people
and our our culture of lies i i would
like to look at this as an opportunity
which is why today i'm michael knowles
and officially throwing my hat in the
ring for 2022 pakistani belly dancer of
the year i am brave i am beautiful and
if you don't give me the award you are a
bigot you know what time it is it's
almost christmas time and movement the
original watch brand to break all the
rules is right there for you how did
movement start you know movement started
because two college dropouts who didn't
want to overpay for a nice watch
they started this great company it
became extremely popular they brought
you really really nice watches at a
really reasonable price they cut out the
middleman they've got a ton of other
stuff even beyond the watches they've
got hundreds of watches blue light
glasses sunglasses super cool jewelry
you can stuff your stockings with all
this sort of stuff it was the best
present that i've ever gotten for my
father and my stepmother i got them
movement watches one year and they by
they loved it much more than any watch
i've gotten them i
have had a lot of watches i have a lot
of watches some are very very expensive
some are not very expensive and i love
my movement watches especially the
revolver check out the revolver that's a
top one and they've got a great
automatic watch too so go check that out
be the winner this christmas season with
a gift from movement mvmt.com
knowles that is mvmt.com
knowles and join the movement the time
athlete of the year is someone who chose
not to be an athlete now obviously
simone biles i'm not familiar with her
work at all but i'm told that she's a
very good gymnast but she's not
being given the award because she's a
good gymnast she's not being given the
award in the years where she did
gymnastics
she is being given the award
specifically explicitly for refusing to
be an athlete
much as bruce jenner was given the award
woman of the year specifically because
he's
a man he's not a woman
nor mcdonald's the late great nor
macdonald had a bid on this where where
he said you know now we're told that
bruce jenner is stunning and brave and
you know he might be brave but i don't
think he's stunning
i don't think he's beautiful
not very many women you know even women
women in their 60s are like supermodels
right so
it's j it's just it's a lie it's a lie
that we're being forced to believe in
these people are being given awards to
make the award
a lie
where does this come from
i think this comes from
a natural inclination in the christian
west which is to take the side of the
victim
in pagan cultures in non-christian or
before that non-jewish cultures you
don't you don't really see a lot of
concern for the victim you see a lot of
this is what the uh
philosopher and sociologist renee girard
pointed out that you see a lot of
scapegoating you see a lot of uh
attacking a victim
unanimous violence against a victim and
then you scapegoat and then the the
civilization can move on you see
cultures beginning with founding murders
taking the side of the murderer not the
side of the murder and then in the
jewish scriptures and then in its
fulfillment in christianity you see god
taking the side of the victim and we do
that and that is expressed in leftism
that's expressed in woke-ism that you
always want to take the side of the
person who seems weaker
the the person who seems to be the
underdog and and this can be taken to a
point of absurdity
now where because
bruce jenner for instance suffers from
confusion about his sex because he is in
that way marginalized
we need to
take it to the complete other extreme
and say he's the most beautiful stunning
woman in the world
because simone biles claims to have had
some mental problems before the event
and really she just said yeah i don't
feel like it i'm not having fun because
she's not having a good time we need to
say she's the greatest athlete in the
whole wide the best athlete of the year
even though she didn't really do
athletics this year
that takes things to a point of
absurdity but it it does seem to be in
our dna it reminds me of a line from
chesterton who points out that
the modern world isn't terrible because
it's so bad
it's terrible in some ways because it's
too good
it's not the vices that are getting us
it's the virtues when you take one
virtue out of context and you blow it up
out of proportion and you disregard all
the other virtues then you can end up in
a bad place and that's where we are
right now did you like that clip be
honest i can take it i did you well if
you did even if you didn't please
subscribe ring that bell get the
notifications for when i have new videos
out
and if you really want to get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast type
in the michael knowles show boom
subscribe
boom five star review boom
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you